hello good morning good morning to all of
you who are in the part of america good
evening to those of you who are studying me
going from spain or from europe the first thing to
introduce myself is jesús martínez
superior technical palace in
occupational risk prevention and manager of the
animal facility  of the ciemat the ciemat is a
research center of the government of
spain' focused on energy research
and in which we play
a part in the study of the effects
of the energy use
of waste energy management and
its effect on the  people's health
today I am going to talk about safety and health
at work a small conference
on this point in part you can
ask us some questions to
take advantage of the fact that we are online and that we
can communicate I would appreciate it
if
you would like to ask any questions in the questions and answers part  observation
enter them in which we can they will be
answered live and if not at the end
of the conf  erence, we will answer
these questions.
The first thing I wanted to tell you is,
in our opinion, think about whether you want to
answer
what are the main risks
to safety and health at work that
we associate with working with laboratory animals.
I don't know if anyone wants to be the  first or
if you think about them and others
normally when we do
this people usually answer
on a biological basis let's say that's how
people think about allergies and it is true in
zoonoses in infections that
animals can transmit to us and also
in the damage that can cause us  the
animal itself
this is true and I suppose that many
of you who are on the other side will have
thought about these three questions we are
going to leave it there and later we will go
over it
today we are going to talk basically about
legislation a very small part do not be
scared that nobody
run away right now that this is going to be just a
difference what is the work with
experimental animals  ation where
you will see that zoonoses,
allergies and damage from animals will
be represented by other risks that
also exist in animal facilities,
biological, chemical, psychosocial, we are
going to end up with a fair analysis of
the risks of what really happens in
a facility,
let's go  to start talking about legislation
with examples here you see a person who
is working on a construction site and who due to an
accident has this type of problem
the first legislation is also a case
of evolutionary convergence let's say
all legislations have evolved more or
less the same started with  a
compensatory concept this is a concept from
approximately the late 19th of the
early 20th century in which the
person when they had an accident was
compensated for the damages and they were
compensated proportionally it is not the
same that the person died on the
job than  had an injury and a hand injury is
not the same as a
good foot injury was a h  to bring up a point of view
this point of view is
currently maintained but it seems that this was not
enough for us we did not need anything
else being compensated for injuries is
basic but it is not the only thing we want
at a given moment we went on to the next
point that  It was a concept that was
no longer just compensatory and not reactive
when there was an accident
the occupational health and safety inspector would come and
look and say good about this
work from now on everyone is going
to wear a helmet
the helmet is not that I have stayed  very
nice but there it is,
each accident is investigated and measures are taken
to prevent accidents from recurring,
this, as well as the compensatory concept,
is also maintained right
now but we want to go further, it
seems little to us that things remain in
that we have to have  an accident for
that accident to be compensated is not a good idea
because it went to the concept that is the one
that has introduced us into European legislation
and it is a concept that is almost d  the
preventive 21st century the prevention technician is
going to come or look, he is going to
see that there is a man hammering and he is
going to say here we are going to put a grave
and that way we prevent the bricks
from falling of course the man is going to wear his
helmet  In addition, since there is a second weight,
we are going to put up another net to
prevent someone from peeking out there and falling.
Since this man has been hearing that
bricks were falling through that area of ​​the work,
we are going to put a fence so that
even if he goes looking  above,
we do not fall into the hole
that is the current concept of
occupational risk prevention
the technician is going to see the job,
evaluates the risks that the
job has and proposes measures to prevent
accidents from being caused
now I am going to propose  another other philosophy
another thought do you see any difference
between this brick
and this other
I want to think that I am a good person and
that those who enabled the brick that
hits him in the head out of empathy found  You may think there is a certain difference
but from the point of view of
prevention there is no difference, they are
two identical events. In fact, if you see
this pyramid you will see that
the brick that falls on the user's head is
the eye brick that is at the bottom.
high number one ten bricks have
had to hit another part of the body
causing the injuries
30 bricks have hit this gentleman or
have fallen into a pile of glass in
a bag of cement they have caused some
damage
and up to 600 bricks have fallen  They have
been seen to fall and no one has said anything. How
can we act in prevention? By
detecting one of those 600 bricks,
calling the prevention technician and
avoiding the successive chain of damages and
vendors that are going to lead us to the
accident,
we are all part of prevention.  and
this is something that we have to be
very clear about
if you want to know with this we have
finished with the legislation on the other
hand the principles of prevention if
you want to know at  go on
occupational risk prevention in Spanish I would
recommend two web pages on the one
hand the National Institute for Occupational Safety
and Hygiene a Spanish center
is the reference in Spain for this type
of knowledge
I would also recommend
the Chilean Health Institute another page  also
very good where you can find a lot of
information
in the Spanish study of
gender insurance the work we have what are
called the technical notes of prevention
are the free
downloadable documents the short ones of five or
six pages in which you can
find information on practically
any  topic of prevention that you want to
consult if you put here in this part
of marking you put what you want nothing
work with blood carcinogens warehouse
of chemical products even if you put an
animal facility you will see that there are
technical prevention notes for practically
anything
if this happens we will see it
for  For example, there is a technical note on
prevention.  The information about working with
experimental animals is a short note of
five or six pages and where
most of the risks are exposed and how to
prevent them,
on the Chilean page we have another thing
that we don't even like very much, which is
that there is a section on all of them.
biological risks where you can
find all the legislation and all the
matters related to three non-
biological ones,
well, if we see this technical note on
prevention, we will see that the damages are the
risks due to the
handling of animals and are typical
of animals, as we have  Said before
carriers of diseases allergies
bites damage scratches in many
cases due to the research
we carry out with animals
let's not forget that our animal facilities
our vivariums are not zoos
we have animals and we are doing
things to them that we would never want them to
do to us so this has
a  certain risk associated with work
and in Spanish legislation s  It is said
that transgenics also have
their own dangers due to
genetic modifications, well I don't
know, it is true that many times
transgenic animals have
altered immune states and this can be a
way to have some type of
biological risk in our center, we have
generated  More than 200 transgenic lines
and we have not yet generated any. I
eliminated cholera toxins with the
desquamation of the skin, since it is not
necessary to exaggerate in that sense, but it is
good
if we see the damages due to
animals and we study what is the use
of animals at the moment  In Europe we see
that most of the
laboratory animals that we use are mice.
The damage that a mouse can do when
biting you is more a damage of pride
than a real damage. In fact, many
times we do and look at the hand and when
we look we don't.  it has bitten our finger, but
it has simply bitten our glove
and we have given you the same cry, there is no,
my God, it does not  a lot of damage but well it
is true that a megaton when it is
immobilized tends to bite us
a pleasant one is already another problem an
open one if it bites us yes it
can hurt us and that may be true what
happens is that the idea is
natural  It does not tend to move something we have
had to do that has really
bothered the animal for it to
bite the other rodents
mainly rabbits can give us problems due to
scratches but always due to mishandling
because if we put the animal with its
paws resting on our  body or we
leave it to another person offering it
with the legs forward because it is
relatively easy for the animal
to scratch
cold-blooded animals, normally
fish because they cannot look at us in a
disturbing way but beyond that they
cannot have many  more damage the
truly dangerous carnivores
the apes and others, well, this does have to be
handled carefully,
the problem that we always have  We have a
problem of damage by animals,
whatever we say, it is our fault,
the animal is forced to bite
us and we have to work so
that they cannot always bite us, the
damage is associated with mishandling of the
animal, I don't care what you say
people, of course, it's that they were in a hurry, it's
that they were alone, well, it's your fault, not the
animal's,
on the other hand, the diseases that
animals transmit to us, where one
showed gnosis, common diseases
between animals and humans in
general, we tend to assign zoonoses
to diseases that pass from
animals to man, but you have to
remember that all the islands are also
passed from man to
animals, okay,
well, I don't know if it makes much sense to
talk about zoonoses at this time if
you see some prevalence tables here  I
do not know if you will see them well because of
zoonotic diseases their prevalence
both in marked North America and in
ea and in Europe is minimal they
sing viruses  info core or meningitis I
might get or viruses although it
is not clear that the viruses are zoonotic because they are
believed to be species specific since they
have a minimal prevalence
anyway in our guild in the guild
of laboratory animals there have been
people who have died from  the info core
meningitis and hanta virus these
diseases are also seen more in the usa
because many
wild containers coexist in the areas of
national parks and others and if
you google deaths by avid people
isidro stinks well normally you will
find news but  They are more
linked to this.
The fact is that wild innovators
do tend to carry the disease and it
can be a source of contamination for
our animals in the laboratory, we must
keep it under control
if we see bacteria that can be
zoonotic, well, here we can also
see well.  a certain amount that
staphylococci can normally appear but the truth is that
Also, if we analyze ourselves,
about a third of the population would be
carriers of staphylococci.
Another bacterium that appears a lot and that in
Europe has been fashionable with some
problem are analytical beta streptococci
, the typical streptococcus of
pharyngitis.
We must find our
animal facility.  but normally we have
linked it more to people with
pharyngitis who go to work at the animal facility
than to animal diseases, but
well, it is possible for them to find it
if we talk about metazoans, parasites and
others, currently it is very difficult, in the
past, pineapples those of
dermatophytes were a disease  common
mainly linked to
trapping cats and things like that but right now the
truth is that they are not found
so you might ask yourself can we
talk about zoonoses in the laboratory
because if you look at this table and see the 'top
ten' of zoonoses that are transmitted
In laboratories you will see that, for example,
brucellosis is a canonical zoonosis and d  The
book Kukoc fever follows the other
zoonosis in the book, thyroid, which in
some cases can be hepatitis,
which for those who work with primates,
it can also be zoonotic, tularemia,
tuberculosis, dermatophytes in the 'top
ten' of diseases that are
transmitted in the laboratory.
the majority are zoonoses it makes sense to
talk about this
well we say that numerically zoonoses
are very few but
nevertheless here you see a zoonosis that has
occurred in our center this animal is
triple immunodeficient a
manuel is not displayed and if you see it I will try
mark oslo
here on the muzzle it has a small bump
if we grow this bump you see here
a culture medium where it grows
I tell you that this is a
selective growth for staphylococcus aureus
you will say it is this other culture plate
because the fingers of the caretaker  Normally,
the caregiver works well, works with
gloves, disinfects his hands and so on,
but no one is free to make mistakes.  I know when to
decide on a mobile
phone call that I should not take in an
animal facility but that it is an urgent call,
you answer it, you don't realize it,
and when you want to go back to work
because you contaminate the mixed animal, it is
possible to pass on
how zoonoses are controlled,
basically no one  You are going to have
animals with zoonoses in your animal facility,
normally no one consents to having this,
what is usually done is to demand
health certificates at source that
the animals come with a
health guarantee that they do not carry zoonotic diseases,
check our own
colony, carry out external controls many
times because they do not  we have to be
sure of what we do analyze
sick animals when we have
suspicions we have to analyze those animals it is
not enough to sacrifice them and say
well nothing happens this is sacrificed that
's it and we have to work according to
safety standards and our level  of
biosecurity with that in principle we
should not have this type
another of the classic problems in
animal facilities are allergies
allergies are immune-type reactions
mediated by the presence of an allergen
in animal facilities hundreds of
allergens coexist unfortunately we
could be an allergen museum
from the skin and hair flakes of animals
pedestrians, much more serum proteins
from mouse urine, for
example,
all kinds of powders from feed, flour and
so on, this is a classic disease in
prevention, baker's lung due to
exposure to starch dust,
latex from gloves, chemical products
and then many  alcohol facilitators,
for example, everyone to
work has the habit of fumigating
the tables and benches with alcohol on the
work surfaces. As this alcohol evaporates,
it will irritate our respiratory tracts
and will make it easier for
allergens to reach us much more
deeply  than would be normal,
the typical allergy in the
laboratory animal is the type  1 mediated
by a contact that sensitizes
through antigen-presenting
cells, the lymphocyte arrives, the
lymphocyte will produce antibodies that
will sensitize the mast cell and in the
second contact with the allergen the
mast phyto will release its mediators and
we will  having allergy symptoms
the prevalence of this disease is
enormous we are talking about 20 to 30
percent of the exposed workers
there is a genetic condition
called the topia a
genetic predisposition to suffer from allergies that causes symptoms to develop
much sooner  and it is
much worse to face the disease from
this case
of course it has always been said that
smoking and contact with other
animals smoking and having a lot of
contact with different species
promotes allergies and what is
proven because this is more or  less
controversial what is evident that the
contact time ends up generating
allergies there you see a malicious graph
It is set to be a bit scary in
which cases accumulate and see how the
accumulation of cases in relation to
time is a direct proportion. The
longer we are in contact, the more
people develop allergy symptoms,
the contact time with allergens must be cut.
The clinic has undergone two studies,
one that was carried out in Spain that has not been
published and another that has been carried out in
Anaheim in the USA,
mainly affecting the upper airways
and not discharging things, all
things tear and there are some people who have
aging skin problems.
Small pimples, erythema, edema and
so on,
and who has serious
respiratory problems, asthma or
respiratory pressure problems, and so on.
Well, if you see the data, they are quite
homogeneous, so we must think
that these percentages of people
affected are more or less continuous,
how can we control the  allergies
in spain' everyone should be the
same I know that it is like that you can not
dis  criminalize anyone because of their health condition,
we cannot say that a person
does not work because it is topical because they
have that genetic predisposition to
suffer from allergies, however, we
can say that you are atopic, you have
to take three times more care than a
normal person and you have  You have to be
aware that you are exposing yourself to
a health hazard.
Normally, the facilities have
quite good environmental control. In
fact, there are times when we talk about
individually ventilated bucks,
yaks, and this seems to them to be a
technological design to increase
safety.  of the animals and increase the
density of cages this is not the case, they were
designed in the usa in the nh to extract
the air from the cages and prevent
allergens from dispersing in the
rooms they are safety equipment at their
origin
of course you have to use x  that
avoid exposure to allergens separate changing rooms
masks can be
used for mobile phones and others due to  Much of
our work in general has a
lot of humidity, the animal facilities have
very high humidity, the humidity
favors the particles to aggregate and to
be less allergenic because they aggregate
and are unable to breathe. I know from
individuals with a larger volume of the type
of model
the  Allergy is a disease and
doctors have to treat it as such, many
times you ask prevention services
and prevention technicians
to help you with these issues
when health issues have to be
treated by the doctor and I would ask
you to treat this  and always with your good doctor,
another of the obvious risks are
the three biological agents through
which biological agents reach us,
the most normal thing is through the respiratory tract,
inhaled,
and you came up with a way to
avoid inhaling
biological agents, a very  simple
a mask simply with a
mask we will probably avoid
98% of the biological agents that
could  let's inhale
very simple another life is the oral route
the ingestion of people is much more
common than it seems and it is embarrassing
because it means that we have put
the animal in contact with our mouth to
do that is embarrassing it is a failure of
basic hygiene
always be  He works with gloves and
never leaves the animal facility without washing his
hands.
I don't know if I have taught
my children many things, but I taught them that
they wash their hands before
eating and after going to the bathroom.
your father a little before eating after
going to the bathroom and when going to the animal facility you have to
wash your hands accordingly well because
with that that route is canceled
the parenteral route much more than it
seems if you remember a few years
ago when the  AIDS it was discovered that
in the practice of encapsulating the needles it
was a way of contagion for the
huge nurses of the AIDS virus.
You have to be careful, they are
accidents, but it is a route of contagion
that we have present there,
another very normal life, it is the eye route.
I would like to ask how many of
you work with laboratory glasses.
Hopefully there are many, but it
is not normal in the field in which
we move and yet
everyone is very worried about when
you go to an eyepiece an animal not to generate
a gas embolism you take the
syringe
you give it some French toast to remove the
air droplets and you do this
to release the air bubble at the
tip  An aerosol will be generated from the syringe
that will very easily
reach your eyes. Be careful with
this and when you do that, put a
disinfectant cotton on the tip of the
syringe and everything is solved.
skin in
general is a good space for a
good barrier against infections
what happens if you have
ever removed the glove after having
used it for more than  half an hour you will see that
your skin is completely macerated
and no longer has that integrity it had
before if we put on the gloves wrong and
let our glove slip into our glove
why don't we adjust it to the gown because it
is a size larger than it should be
yes  Inside that glove, some particle gets into us,
some organic remains
will be touching our
skin for as long as we
wear the glove. Think about that when you
put on the gloves,
if it does not say here in percentages, then the
aerosols what  they would be witches
sprays spatters
punctures syringes and needles with
sharp objects even animals are
also considered possible ways of counting
I hope it doesn't pass this is
a somewhat old survey but I hope no one
pokes you with their mouths at this point of
course it will  you're left with your mouth
stop doing it tomorrow no you don't have to
do more
good it seems we talk about
anything but it's not like that this is it  an
uncertain reality here you are seeing the report
of the last six months in spain'
of diseases related to
occupational diseases related to
biological agents in red you are
seeing allergies which would be cases of
allergy and schümann beyond 800 and in
green losing infections  The
chronos is that there are about 22 identified
in Spain, it is not much, but they are and there they
are and they are generally problems, if
not serious, at least very annoying. Keep it in
mind and know that this exists,
well, other risks that we have, the
experimental procedures,
normally we will handle products.
Dangerous on many occasions is the
object of the experiment and we are not going to be
able to avoid it in any way. Well, what
you have to do is use
adequate protective equipment. You have to keep
in mind that a latex glove is not
universal protection, each risk
requires  your protective equipment
nitrile vinyl latex gloves
or whatever are  suitable for depending on
what things if you look in the
technical notes on prevention and gloves you will see
a table of resistance to the different
products you
always have to plan what to do
in the case of emergencies
we cannot have all this information
which is the right glove that I am going to
to do in an emergency because it is the
safety data sheet of the products
all the products in europe and I think that
in any part of the world when they are
marketed they are accompanied by their
safety data sheet
we are going to see one more thing for example
we are going to see it is a case  so that you think
we are going to take a histology biopsy
and to fix it we are preparing a
formalin solution tampo nothing
that is the universal fixative normally we
take tve it is going to make phosphate to which
we add a little concentrated formaldehyde
well we have been measuring the buffer
we  They have wet the gloves and when we pick up the
bottle of formaldehyde it falls to the ground,
it bursts and the concentrated formaldehyde spills out.
Or the soil that we should
do
well, perhaps some of them know, most of them
without thinking about the courses, left
here that most of them would not know what to do,
there will be someone who says, we try to put an
absorbent on it, we pick it up with a mop,
what we run off depends on
, we don't know.  In general,
if you see the safety data sheet, the first
thing it says is that it has done self-protection
in formaldehyde, it is toxic by inhalation. If
you are trying to do something with that
formaldehyde, what we are going to do is inhale
it and your lungs are going to fix what
you are going to do.  the joy of the coroner
because the coroner will not have seen
better-fixed lungs in his life the
signature came that nice but of course it
is not usually appropriate to be the subject of a
coroner
but to go warn it has stayed because we
are leaving we all close the door and for a to
come  firefighter with
self-contained breathing apparatus and a fan that
removes that formaldehyde from our
installation that is what should be
done
I want to tell you that no  there are so many
truly dangerous products if
you work in a normal laboratory I
think we are talking about 68
dangerous products no more please
read the safety sheet in this
safety sheet you will find all
this is not intended to double
memory country but it will stay with you  in the head,
perhaps that acids can be
neutralized,
that biological spills must be
added with a disinfectant, have some
notions in your head that allow you to
act when we have this type of
problem,
another of the very common and very
peculiar risks in animal facilities are
psychosocial risks the
social interaction of the worker with the rest of the
world here I am looking at a study that
I carried out a few years ago in
which a population of the seca was established the
Spanish society of laboratory animal science
about 700 people from
the seca responded  to this survey
compared with a reference population,
a population that are the
areas  s yellow in which it is adjusted to
our population, that is, if our
union has 60% women, the
reference population has 60%
women, if our average age is 25
years old,
our population of
violence is not.  adjusts to these
factors
and there you see in blue the factors that are
normal in red those that are negative and
in green those that are positive
what would I highlight because on the one hand the
sense of work
we believe that what we do is
worth it we are all convinced  what we
are doing we are going to show the cure
for cancer an improvement in the
living conditions of a species or an animal
or ourselves but nevertheless if
you look a little further back we have what is
called the lion conflict we know
that what  we do is fine but we
realize that the animals suffer and that
does not generate an internal conflict
and that is how we cannot do it any other
way another positive peculiarity of
our work is that we have  We have a lot
of control over what we do in the
animal facility,
we have our own way of doing it,
influence, we control our
work times and we believe that they have
meaning and development in our
work, that is very good and negatively,
you will see the demands are the
needs for knowledge.  the
needs of manual and
sensory skills and the emotional needs
I feel that working in lethal dose 50
and I knew how to do it but right now my
work has gone up to the ips it is up to
the induced pluripotent cells
we have totally changed in which to
be learning every day they do
There is a lack of tremendous cognitive demands, you
have to know a lot to be
in this world
and then you have to have
sensory demands. Animal facilities
are often designed to be comfortable
for the animals, not for the
workers, and in that sense,
we often have to carry out our
work that  it's a precision job
injecting a sample into a vein in a
mouse requires great precision in
conditions that require a lot of
sensory and
emotional demands because if we have induced
a tumor in our animal and we see it
with the tumor growing, we must have a
stone heart not to  suffer for the
animal and we all do it
well another Maria that attracts a lot of
attention is that of the double presence
the double presence represents the
reconciliation of work life and
family life how our
work interferes in our social life and in this
case well  It exists, it is true that one can
work as an administrator in a
factory and the siren sounds at five in
the afternoon and one says see you later, I'm leaving.
If you're working in an animal facility,
you're not going to leave until you finish, you
can't leave animals untreated.  you
can't leave animals without food you
can't leave things half done
that means that conflict
we at our center
do a course on
occupational risk prevention online
at the ciemat and we always do a test for the students who sign up for this
course, a
simpler psychosocial test in this
test you see that in the yellow zone and
already indicating more or less serious dangers
because there is, for example, the load  What
we said before about the demands, the
necessary attention, the complexity of the
tasks, the consequences of errors
often burden us a lot and
lately I suppose that in part due to the
problems of the crisis, since
other variables are beginning to appear, such as
interest in  The worker,
the people, perceive that there is no longer so much
security at work, our boss, if
we ask him what will become of my
contract, well, I don't know, we'll
see if the money is such a
consequence of the crisis that
we are seeing in Spain.  and that in recent years
it is reflected in this type of surveys,
well, we ourselves follow what is
in the animal facilities that we
have seen and  What we believe can be
controlled is dust and aerosols
all aria animals in which there are
suppliers by definition the suppliers
will generate dust when eating
and they have a certain amount of dust in
many cases the installation of age
ventilated a correct design  of the
installation will solve this
problem
the explosions we use many
volatile many flammable volatile products
ether alcohol
disinfectants and in many cases
storing these products
improperly can lead to
problems also the noise in our
animal facilities there is a lot of equipment that
makes noise from the washing  yaks
to which any type of machinery
, car washes and others, when
we have controlled this noise,
we have reached levels of 71
decibels.
severe level we have also seen load handling
as a problem  It is
necessary to take it seriously, measures must be taken and
the measures in this case are the training
and awareness of the
workers that the loads must be handled in
an appropriate manner,
if we continue with the
general protection recommendations for the animal facility, it
must be  a closed enclosure that
cannot be accessed by anyone other than who has
to access it is not a zoo
visitors cannot come people cannot come to
see how beautiful the animals are the
animal facility created and always marked with
the sign of biological danger here we
will be able  Being exposed to allergens,
biological agents, and you have to mark it in
a convenient way, this is also scary and
so many people who would normally
try to come to see what the
little mice in the animal facility are like, well, they are going to
say how cute there is a mark here
that is scaring me. Let's go.  leave it
another problem that we have seen many
times is burns the thermal contacts
and beige two systems in one
heat system  from dry heat a dry heat stove
that is working at 170 degrees if
you see it has reached 85 degrees from 170
degrees to 85 degrees celsius the machine
has cooled down but at 85 degrees celsius the
products burn a lot do not
observe handling until the equipment
It is in a safe situation and it is always
necessary to handle hot loads with
the
appropriate personal protective equipment with insulating gloves that
allow us to handle hot things
and we will see later how this is one of
the problems we have had in
our animal facility,
another problem is radiation.
ultraviolet we use ultraviolet
because it is capable of interacting with the
DNA of the bacteria and due to a photolytic effect it
will generate a new one without
having any intercrossing of their DNA and it will
kill the bacteria
because you may think that what kills
a bacterium  It will not be bad for
you if it is, you should never work
with the ultraviolet on, I say this
because unfortunately I have  We have sometimes seen
people who, by mistake or through
ignorance, worked with
the ultraviolet. I also have to take into account that not all ultraviolet rays are dangerous.
the discotheques
and the one that attracts insects but will not
be able to cause us any harm.
Well, now we are going to analyze
what really happens in an installation.
Do you remember that when we started this
talk we suggested that you think  What
types of risks could you
be exposed to by working in an
animal facility?
I think and I don't think I'll be too wrong,
most of you have thought about zoonosis,
allergies, damage from animals, maybe
someone has thought about the
experimental procedure in injections, it's so good,
right, but here  the risks that
we specifically as a
prevention technician and identified in our
facility falls falls at the same or at a
distance  into level accidents in
handling objects and projections
things that are hanging or that can
fall to treatment because the shelves
move the washing tunnels the racks
everything can be moved in an animal facility and
the relatively easy handling of
loads the overexertion and the
repetitive movements especially
of animal workers
burns exposure to dust and
aerosols explosions we have already
discussed of course
animal accidents a lot of glass and
surgical accidents exposure to smoke and
exposure to chemical agents
I would like you to think about
how many we should have asked
to  who would have told us about these risks
in an animal facility, it is
good if we see which of these risks
have led to a person having
gone to the company doctor has gone because
the accident has caused damage are
these falls overexertion burns
accidents by animals accidents with
material  glass and surgical and
exposi  tion to chemical agents
these are the accidents that
have really happened in our facility and I
am afraid that in general now we are going to see it it
is quite common and if I tell you which
are the ones that have given people to their homes
the ones that have caused a  Lower America
that it has been important to send
a person home for at least three days
because these are
falls on efforts and burns
to how many new others I would have had to
ask so that at first they would have
said that the danger of working in an
animal facility is the  falls,
overexertion or burns, or
all of you who sign up for the
videoconference, I don't think any of them
would have said this, because that's just
what really sent people home,
what is the problem that we both
perceive them socially and we perceive
them based on  our knowledge
and our experience we
move in a biosanitary area and
then we focus our knowledge
on the risks in that area  or and we
focus on allergies on zoonoses on
damage caused by animals and yet
our workplace is
a workplace just like any other and
what happens to us happens anywhere
in life we ​​fall we hurt ourselves
by pulling a  I take out or we get burned
if we put numbers to this you will see that
more than half of our accidents
are cuts and punctures with
surgical glass material and needles, 53
percent are followed by falls.
If you enter with
leggings, you should not enter with a
boot but if you think about it normally,
we enter the animal facility. The floors are
shiny, they are easy to wash,
disinfect and others, we put on some
leggings, some booties, there may be water, there
may be small pellets of feed in these
of feed it is very easy to fall
the next in the ranking is the
overexertion people carry the cages
four or five cages as many as they
can until they  That they come here
to take them like this and leave with all of them in
a single trip, people get a lot of
damage because of this, the burns and the
chemical products are few but in
general serious and there you see 7
percent of damages due to animals,
well, well,  It is evident that even though
it is our fault, these things
happen
but they do not happen only to us.
We are a small center in a
relatively peripheral country, but here
I am looking at a survey that was carried out
a few months ago among the people who publish
in Nation.
These are not stupid, they are people who know a
lot because they have been able to publish and
if not and if you look here more or less if
we add the number of accidents and the
proportions of accidents you will see
that their risk of accidents is
dangerously similar to ours, it is very  similar,
the only thing that stands out is that the people who
publish in fact, because they have many more
problems with chemical products,
the percentage of animals is added to the percentage of
bites, punctures and  others but that is
the main risk and the others are
all very similar
logically we move in
a very molecular and cellular biology field
and not so much in a field of
toxicology or chemical products
so it is normal for them to have many
more chemical accidents  than us
but for the rest the distribution of
accidents is very similar
if we analyze how these
accidents occur you will see and I don't know if you will
see it but I am going to mark it with a pencil
shouting
because in principle if you see this
graph most of the  accidents are due to
unsafe acts the blue part
of the distribution circle many of the
accidents are without sick leave
most of the accidents are without
sick leave
and most are very minor accidents of
a mild nature but well this is so the
frequency limit  the number of
accidents per hours worked
remains very constant in general and is
at 4.22, it is quite a lot and the point that is
most injured is the fingers of the  hand
with 14 percent you have to be very
careful where you put your fingers I
don't know how this has sounded but hey that's
the idea
if we continue and almost to finish because
we are going to leave some time for
questions we are going to talk about what  Is the
greatest risk numerically in our
animal facilities that are sharp sharps,
cuts and punctures in this sense or
is a recently published Spanish standard included here
in which it is
about preventing injuries caused by
sharp and sharp objects at
work first of all  It should be noted that the
capping of the needles has been totally prohibited.
When one uses a needle, he has the
habit of putting it back on. The little cap has
reached the microphone. Sorry,
putting the cap back on and the syringe is covering
the needle.
It is prohibited by law in
Spain and it should be a
moral prohibition for you
if we continue, we must take into account that
sharp objects have  and that
handling them with great care no one would
leave it is a scalpel to your children
because because you know that it is a very dangerous thing to
always have it in your
head
you have to handle them with great care and
not only when they are used when they are used
when they are left and when  they are discarded
when they are thrown away in all their use they are
dangerous not only when we are
using them when we forget them when we
discard them also not to use the needles
what I say again never ever
handle them after use
if we serve we must have
special containers for their disposal  some
containers that are capable of withstanding
the needles and that are not easily
pierced
these containers you all know and
we are going to link this with the
fifth recommendation here you will see an
instruction that is very difficult to
understand apparently you see here this
instruction that puts here a grace is
a black cookie two arrows and some
letters that say filling limit
this is d  very difficult to understand I
suppose none of you understand what
this means
if you don't understand but then
mysteriously no one does one of the
big problems with these containers is
that people fill them completely until
they stick out like a
Japanese tree and there are the  scalpels sticking
out of the mouth and so on that is a
great danger if someone squeezes those scalpels
they will pierce the walls and someone
can do a lot of damage with them
always respect the fill limit
and it should always be the person who
works or should be the person  who
works the one who is in charge of leaving that
object in its disposal site many
times we leave them on top of the pass
we are cutting the animal we make the
cut and throw away the scalpel it stays
here next to it and we forget about it a bit and
it can be  a very big danger
one thing that must be done is that
objects should never be left on any
surface another person who comes to
support a hand  or come over to see what
we are doing, a cut can be carried out
in a very silly way,
we should not put sharp objects
in our Europe. Those of us
who come from the vet are
very used to
carrying pre-filled syringes here in the cow's pocket,
no.  Well, we are going to do the anesthesia and
we put in atropine, we put the same good thing, well,
that is a very bad praxis if at
any given moment you bend over or do
anything you can stick that needle into yourself, you can
also put scissors, scalpel and
others in the pockets of the cows or of
laboratory pajamas of course
never leave sharp materials
in europe that go to
wood people who wash can have a
serious accident and of course never
leave it in normal garbage cans
because people who collect garbage
can also have a serious  accident
with this
well I think that with this more or less
what I wanted to tell you has finished and
now with your permission I am going to
the questions and answers part so that
if someone has any questions,
try to answer them
with a
good point because I don't see any questions, the truth is
that I see a few angel friends,
I appreciate being there on the other side and at the
moment we don't have any questions but
well,
nothing  So, in principle, if you don't
have any questions, well, we're not going
to leave it here. Thank you all very much for
being good. I see a question coming up. I have
n't just seen it because a person from Chile has
stayed here and
there is the possibility of doing their
course.  of biosafety and that it is
certified yes
in the ciemat I take the opportunity to answer
this question in the ciemat right now
on our website there is an active course that
we give on occupational risk prevention
oriented to animal experimentation
this course can effectively be taken
online it is a  virtual course can be taken
from anywhere in the world I
also take this opportunity to say that the people
who are enrolled  ada in cee sacal in the south
american society
of laboratory animal science has a
50 percent reduction in the quota
and from that course a
certification valid in spain is obtained- as
a basic level technician in
occupational risk prevention I'm going for another
carolina vela asks
what is the most common occurrence
of occupational health problems in the
kennels, since it is what was offered in
principle, as well as numerically,
sharp sharps are without a doubt the main
occupational accident that we have in the
kennels due to gravity. I would tell you that
falls are the  Burns and
overexertion, which are the three
that we have found, have
sent people home, although without a doubt,
by far the greatest risk numerically
are cuts and punctures,
manipulation of surgical objects.
Let's go with another question
and a person, a friend, comments.
Manuel, it seems to you that our
examples are very true, it is seen that
people who have experience  You know that
this actually happens there is another
question you have some experience
working with nanoparticles and
security measures
well nanoparticles are one of the
last kings of goss that we have
linked to laboratory animals
we work in research and that
often makes us on the frontier
of what  what is done nanoparticles are
frontiers and so we have
little experience because nanoparticles have not been around for so long,
the truth is that
for example in our course we dedicate
a topic to nanoparticles because we
have realized that it is one of the
emerging Greeks
on the website of the  National Institute
for Safety and Hygiene at Work
Inst you will find technical notes
on prevention if you type
nanoparticles you will find various
technical notes on
nanoparticles because they
are indeed a risk and not much is known about
them and they are becoming more and more  time
more present another question from miami
to see in moderation repetitive movements
how you can reduce the
problems derived from occupational health
related to repetitive movements I have
published a paper in the
seca magazine on the website
vvv punto seca the spanish society
of laboratory animal science punto
es en  the publication of
laboratory animals there is one on
repetitive movements repetitive movements
is a problem of the number of times they are
done how they improve a lot with breaks
you have to do things at work stop
from time to time and it also improves a
lot by
following the workers  The fact that the
worker does not always do the same
task on ventilated days supposes a
lot of repetitive movement load,
since then what must be tried is
that a worker who works at a
ventilated age the next day or in another
part of his day dedicates himself, for
example, to  filling bottles or is engaged
in mopping or cleaning the
walls changing activities  and taking
breaks are the main advice for
repetitive movements. I'm going for another one
for an animal facility that works only with
mice. What type of immunization do you
recommend for the staff?
Two things, firstly, immunization is a
matter for
doctors.  professional of
occupational hazards but if you work only
with mice I would say that it is
essential in general for
everyone and certainly for working with
animals tetanus vaccination
tetanus is a very serious disease that
can take us to the grave and  that at
this point in the century it shouldn't be
a problem everyone should be
vaccinated against tetanus
stop all the work you do here
for example we work a lot with
human blood we do a lot of
stem cell transplants or stem cells from
human blood all that exposure to
Human blood has led us to get vaccinated, for
example, against hepatitis. It
depends on your work, as long as it is
from  tuna and the only thing you do is
manipulate and in tunisia I would
simply stay with a vaccination
against empathy against hepatitis sorry about
tetanus perhaps as a general measure of
prophylaxis for being health personnel and
being half exposed to vaccination
against influenza but not much more  I wouldn't
recommend any other.
I don't know if there are any other questions. They
ask here about the increase in
allergic processes.
This is true and it's a reality.
The improvement in our
health condition seems to be that stopping
having contact with the parasites that
we used to have is one thing that sounds
painful, but having worms is that it
increased our immune system and made it
easier for us not to be so mickey's triquis
and we had much less problems from the
energy and it seems that this lack of
contact with parasites is linking us to
the appearance of allergies as
well  The diesel fumes
from which they started are mentioned a lot as
another source of allergies. The
fact is that it is like that and there are more and more
allergy problems in animals.
God is also like
that.  why not having all the
contact time generates allergies
and contact often comes through the
most unexpected routes, for example,
people who work in animal facilities,
external technicians go down in the himalayas
and when they do their things they go down with their
laboratory notebook and because  They are
professional people and everything they do is
written down in their laboratory notebook.
Then you go to your office. You have been
in the animal facility for 20 minutes and you go to the
office with the laboratory notebook
and you start passing things
and when you turn the page you will notice  a certain
animal smell, not
if it has ever happened to you, you will have
noticed it and it is true every time it happens it is
a leaf, a breath of animal,
what happens with this that you are exposed
not for 20 minutes  that you have been in the
animal facility, but your 8 hours of
workday to the allergens that you have
taken in your laboratory notebook,
that is why you go down to the animal facility without
papers, you change one from Europe, you
should never have the Europe of work and the
Europe of  house or street every time and you have
to try if you are going to be a long time
wash your face your hands and those of
you who have hair that unfortunately
this is no longer a problem for some keep in mind
that many particles that can be energetic are attached to the hair
women who have long hair will
have checked it because when you return from the
animal facility you often smell animal hair
and this is a fact and it is
also usually linked to allergens let's go
for another question
the type of bed or bedding can
cause allergies
the type of bed or the fact can
reduce allergies if not what is the
problem the woods the hardwoods
the concept of hardwood is not a
physical concept but a
p concept  reventivo el chapo el pine are
hardwoods dust from hardwoods is a
huge health problem in the
prevention of occupational hazards because
because they generate many problems of
allergies and pneumoconiosis
the right type can have allergies
not the fact that the fact has or does not have  For
you and what we should look for are made
without dust that do not eliminate particles
because these particles are very, very
dangerous, take that into account more than
the type of milk or if the poplar is better
than the pine or the paper from the
paper six and others  They are better or the corn is
not that it does not release dust is the
fundamental point with another question
hello jesus any recommendations to
design emergency plans
for animals without risk of increasing
the risk of personnel a hug
I don't know who you are from me another hug
But when we talk about safety, the
first thing is people, never lose
sight of
that. I, in charge, is called responsible for
animal welfare and I worry.  really
for the animals the first animal
that worries me is my workers and
myself
when we design the
emergency plans we have to take into account
that what we often cannot do is
try to evacuate one animal animal
by animal emergency plans
can  contemplating what we
call internal evacuations
moving animals away from danger so
that emergency personnel can approach
firefighters or whatever is necessary
and act but we cannot compromise the
safety of people in the event of an
emergency
we have to evacuate we have defined a staff  of
animal evacuation that for a
very limited time will act and will try to
remove the animals from the source of
danger if there is, many
times emergencies do not have to be the
animal facility and perhaps our best
action is to isolate the animal facility close
doors and getting out of there
is difficult is a very controversial issue
and I would tell you that as long as you have  It's a
question people are ahead of anyone.
Let's see another question. Do you
recommend the study and standardization
of particle sizes in
the ice cream shop? Hour
1,
I would say yes, but I would also say
that it is almost not necessary, they are already highly standardized.
the breathable portion the problem with
allergies is that it is only a fraction the
fraction that we call breathable or
inhalable is the one that is going to give us
real problems the one that reaches us
inside the lungs the one that is capable
of generating allergies
that is well studied and  It depends on
the type of animals, the ventilation
that the rooms have and others. Carrying out these
studies can range from very simple to
something as simple as taking a
dust sample and looking for the
particle size to using what are called
breathing simulators, some machines.
that are passing the air
through different ducts that are going to
simulate the different portions of the
respiratory system of the person  az
high roads medium deep roads it
may be fine do not make us as an
animal facility link it to the prevention people they
are the ones who will have these
teams and the ones who will be able to help
to make this type of determination
although I already tell you that in general it is
studied
Let's go for another question where I can
learn about animal facility designs,
well, in part to return the
favor to Juan Manuel Bahamonde and because
it is also true that there is a web page
called bioterios dotcom in which
there is a specific part about
facilities in that part
A
magnificent professional and excellent
person,
Paulina Building, who can help you a
lot in what this is, I would
recommend you connect to bioterios
dotcom, contact the expert in
Paulina Building and also assures that she is
Chilean and speaks Spanish, can
help you without  doubt to find training
on this type of thing
let's go for another question
the equipment  of biosecurity
recommends for visits
actually what I recommend is that you do not
enter visits many times it is
impossible to prevent visitors from entering and in
this case the first and fundamental thing is
leggings most of the contaminants
in the animal facility enter through the feet
we walk on the  street and in the street
we can take anything first you
wear shoes then he told me for the hair it is
very important to cover the hair
whoever has it logically and that is another
very fat route of contamination of course a
mask because when people talk when they
are there they will  releasing particles
droplets aerosols of flow and we can
contaminate people a lot a gown what
you want depends on the security level of
your facility but really
and it is not to be unpleasant what you have
to do is not bring visits to the
animal facility
if you are forced  to take them to
the least secure area and always
airless disguise that also usually gives them a
feeling that well it is safer and more
It is much more important to go dressed up
in the animal facility than anything else, but
really, don't bring visitors. Well, I see here
that our time has run out. I'll
see if there are any more questions. Time
is up, I'm sorry, there are no more
questions. Besides, I think so
Thank you very much everyone for having listened to me. It was a
pleasure to be with you and I hope you have
not been very bored. Well,
one last question about place signs
with a buffer has just arrived. Well, nothing, this has been
all and thank you very much
and a hug to all  I hope to see each other in
the next one.
Well, I see here another question and I don't know, it
seems that we are still on the air
and thank you very much from Colombia.
that they are going to invite us
and I will be delighted to see you there and
of course it will be a pleasure to help you in
whatever you want.
I am delighted to have seen them.
Well, apparently now they should be
finished, the presentation should be speeded up,
but hey,
they ask me as a last question that
I am going to be able to answer because
the moderator is telling me that we have finished
that I want recommendations we would have
for chemicals
and honestly, I forgot like that in a hurry
because it is  and the Lord telling me to
cut the best recommendation go to the
website of the national institute for
safety and hygiene at work in
Spain and in the technical notes on
prevention with chemicals there you will
have everything from how to store them how to
dispose of what equipment they are  Shared
products are compatible and which ones are not,
to maintain them you will have all the
information without any problem on the
website of the National Institute of
Safety and Hygiene at
Work I have to leave you because they already tell me
here that we have finished so thank you very
much  new and really a pleasure